[Music]
the Disney casting Department has
brought two world stars like Ryan
Gosling and Britney Spears but who are
the latest crop of young X Disney stars
getting ready to take Hollywood by storm
if you are a first-time viewer click the
red subscribe button and enjoy today we
are discussing 10 amazing Disney child
stars transformations sky Jackson Disney
star sky Jackson was just nine years old
when she made her Disney debut on the
hit sitcom Jessie fast forward a few
years and we can tell the years have
been kind even though Jackson is still
in her teens she is all grown up and
looking glam she's been able to
experiment with makeup and her style is
on point all in all we are looking
forward to what is next for this young
Disney star Zac Efron he was the star of
one of the most popular Disney
franchises of all time
High School Musical and since his days
on the Disney big screen Zac Efron
hasn't slowed down this hunky star is
now a Hollywood staple and for good
reason he has managed to transform from
nerdy theater geek to sexy six pack me
in a Hollywood leading man just look at
his transformation from his role in the
big screen version of Baywatch where did
all that body hair come from Bella
Thorne the beautiful Bella Thorne
started her time with Disney when she
was just 12 years old since then she has
been growing up right before our eyes
but it seems like thorn is trying to
shake her Disney star image she has
turned into a stunning young adult and
isn't afraid to strip down for the
camera considering how amazing her body
is and her carefree attitude we don't
blame her
Nick donis 2006 was the first year the
Jonas Brothers appeared on Disney they
quickly became a teenage sensation and
it's clear why they were completely
adorable and the youngest brother Nick
Jonas wasn't an exception but baby
brother Nick shocked the world in 2013
when it seemed like he had transformed
overnight the senior had traded his
curly mop top in or a buzz cut and has
spent some serious time at the gym those
biceps alone are enough to swoon over it
seems like the shy X Disney star has
broken from his shell
Demi Lovato singer Demi Lovato has been
around for so long now that people have
almost forgotten she
once a Disney star after appearing in
Disney's Camp Rock films alongside the
Jonas Brothers Lovato has made a name
for herself Lovato has been open about
her body image and substance abuse
issues but in 2017 she shocked the world
with her latest body transformation
Lovato posted a photo of a selfie to
Instagram looking absolutely flawless
and obviously slimmer she proves that
getting your sweat on at the gym does a
body good
Ross Lynch hit Disney show Austin & Ally
came to an end in 2016 but that hasn't
slowed star rosseland down one bit one
of the biggest transformations fans will
see is spotting Lynch on the big screen
the actor was chosen to star in the
crime drama my friend Dahmer where he
plays infamous serial killer Jeffrey
Dahmer it's hard to imagine such a sweet
guy playing such a sinister role but
when a sneak peak of his Dahmer look was
released the similarities were a bit
uncanny we are sure there will be many
more roles for Lynch that will be far
crys from his Disney roots dove Cameron
she may have been a Disney star but dub
chairman is letting the world know she
is not a little girl anymore
in early 2017 the star did an interview
and photo spread for galore magazine and
all we can say is wow the now
20-something has shed her Disney image
and rocked this Marilyn Monroe inspired
photo shoot there are still hints of
Karen from her teenage days but these
stunning photos prove she is certainly
all grown up Joe Jonas who can forget
the middle brother from the Jonas
Brothers Joe Jonas he was known for his
sweet boy next door looks but since his
contract with Disney expired
he has explored new territories as far
as his looks and music are concerned he
is now the frontman for a popular band
dnce and is known for constantly
changing his looks from flowing blue
locks to shocking the world with a buzz
cut
there is nothing Joe Jonas won't try the
good news is he looks amazing regardless
so keep it up Joe Selena Gomez looking
at her social media following it's easy
to conclude that Selena Gomez is one of
the most popular ex Disney stars ever
it's also easy to see why the
woman has made a complete transformation
from her Disney star days she now has
one of the best solo artist singing
careers and did we mention how beautiful
she is it's like every year she makes a
total style and image transformation and
we love it she has done well stepping
into adulthood
and there's so much more in store for
this stunning young woman dylan and Cole
Sprouse they may not have gotten their
start on Disney but they became
household names because of Disney dylan
and Cole Sprouse made tween girls hearts
flutter with their shows The Suite Life
of Zack and Cody and spin off the suite
life on deck but they said their
goodbyes to Disney and their shows in
2011 since then the boys have really
grown up
Dylan is no longer acting though he
still has his leading man good looks and
koa has dyed his hair dark brown and is
looking more grown-up than ever while he
is still pursuing a career in Hollywood
what do you think of these amazing
Disney child star transformations react
in the comments section below and don't
forget to like this video and subscribe
to the thing
[Music]